four two three - shoot - Jae Crowder
good defense by the Grizzlies Jones
Brandon
[Applause]
against Moran
[Applause]
one of the best players on the planet
against a rookie and a rookie meets the
moment he does it he stays down doesn't
jump put a head fake and then is able to
use his size and length to come up with
a huge block on Kyrie reverie almost
forgot though it could have got the ball
and call the timeout used to buy some
senators Valanciunas fishing reach
Brandon Clark
[Applause]
make people fill any other way with this
two-hand finish here Paul PJ Tucker and
yes that is your starting point guard
for the Memphis Grizzlies and scored if
you don't got it
Jones gerund nasty don't have the open
look we're moving the ball to someone
else who is getting the open look you
look at the points in the paint first
quarter Orlando one that's 16 to 2 14 to
4 for the Grizzlies ladies 3 what's the
young fellow here go behind your back
split that faked the defender take away
finish this off off the glass if
something does no words it's just paint
Zeller with the foul Moran can't convert
the three-point play
Maran down the lane please it up here
holy cow
with seven tenths of a second jammer and
whose near towards the end but on this
one there's not a struggle it's just
about athleticism strength and the
wherewithal to finish amongst three porn
as defenders loved to go left love to
finish with that left hands able to
squeeze through Zeller and get the left
hand finished it's no time left on the
clock the reason had to play D but what
a fantastic finished on a young fella
amongst the trees
well JA 11th in the league in fourth
quarter scoring comes out to Anderson
here is Moran turning on the burgers oh
just watch where he starts it that
starts at the free throw line into the
defensive rebound
[Applause]
this is Ben he runs our four well
beautiful pass and then cool way of what
do you think
welcome to the Brandon Clark poster
Solomon Hill is in jaren Jackson is out
Clark goes to work Anderson to kind of
tip it in this is an adjustment to go to
a reverse he is underneath the basket as
able to reach back with that right arm
to be able to finish and how about the
20 for Mitchell 27 foot bucks out of it
G Valanciunas leads the Grizzlies with
22
[Applause]
then I'll call it there with the
reaching yen
[Applause]
so Utah's over the limit so there still
will be free throws I mean watch this
this is with 40 seconds to go in a tight
game crosses them going away from the
basket throws it in
franchise directors 21 threes in a game
for the Grizzlies I'll try
[Applause]
I'm a gentleman from Jackson
[Music]
[Applause]
process party I mean this is just come
get some
look at this but hey what are you doing
what are you doing whoa hey me and it is
a function of how many times you drive
to the rim but jaw gets a lot of his
shots wad nifty move there that's not
gonna get blocked
start and finish here to the second
floor Solomon Hill off the pump fake
Durant with a pump fake oho better hit
down Oh whoopsie Oh Robinson hand dapple
looking down changes nothing gonna save
this way and whoa whoa whoops whoops
where'd he go where'd he go let me
compose myself hey then knock you down
he had to come up with it he had to
compose himself earth cuz after you make
the movies like okay that did happen and
he's not gonna get back Dillon Brooks
comes away with it long lead Jared slam
shut up by Dillon Brooks and they have
an opportunity at the free-throw line
here but you see the nice throw it hit
Jaron doing a good job of getting down
the floor
Dillon eyes up
[Applause]
and he did that in the face great hustle
great anticipation by my rent and then
just create when he felt it he jumps
here it is like well let me see what
I'll get that out to Tucker
[Applause]
[Applause]
guys really love playing with one
another and they play together and such
a nice fashion we always talk about
Moran what will he do we'll partner
Brooks again see Dylan step backs gun
[Applause]
now is 1780
[Applause]
I'll get some of this Clark covered up
by Porter five to shoot
Moran works against Craig on the
baseline
still with it
[Applause]
Michael Malone was arguing for an
offensive foul they have retooled nicely
you lose the Anthony's Davis you can't
do better than what they were able to
put together
Valentina's is okay in this Parliament
if he didn't come down on his hands but
how about that her old friend look we
catch the ball misses the ball is
nowhere near the best look and it's a
lob from midcourt look at that the only
team that's messing that up because the
Philadelphia Flyers that Norvel Pelle
now appearing on a poster let me
introduce you to Brandon Clark hey 20
Moran find the shoes job got caught in
the air shot clock down to two
desperation three
[Applause]
[Music]
I give you a 26 footer the prisons
haven't been a three-point shooting team
all night but I tell you this much this
young fella is a winner through went
through he only know how to play winning
basketball and because of that this
Grizzlies team is in the playoff hunt
right now Moran he has two of the
Grizzlies five triples tonight
[Applause]
citrus look at the what's more it goes
to Zion Johnson he picks up you guys I
out and Duncan disease pick your poison
on that what it's happening right there
Valanciunas flashing in the pose
[Applause]
[Music]